hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem
clone graph so we're given a reference
to a
node that is in a connected undirected
graph so it's convenient for us that the
graph
is completely connected and all we want
to do is return a
deep copy of that graph in other words a
clone of that graph and for every single
node
we have two things we are given a value
and we're also given a list of its
neighbors so this is what's telling us
you know how the graph happens to be
connected these are the edges
in our graph now if you're not super
familiar with what a deep copy is so
let's say that this
is our example our input graph we're not
just going to create a shallow copy
meaning like this
is the exact same graph like the color
is yellow
for both of these meaning like it's the
exact same graph we didn't actually
create a clone of it
so this is not what we're looking for
this is also not what we're looking for
so this is a
new graph because the color is slightly
different
but you see that the values aren't
exactly how they're supposed to be we
have a
3 here whereas we have a 2 in the
original graph right so basically we
have these two's
values mixed up so that's not what we
want either we want an exact clone so
it has the exact same structure and
values right the values and structure is
the exact same
and this happens to be a new graph this
is not the exact same graph as this one
because this one is blue
whereas this one is yellow so how are we
going to solve this problem well you can
see
i'm going to use a hash map like pretty
much every graph problem and we're going
to use
depth for a search where you can also
use breadth first search if you want but
let me show you the general algorithm
so you can see these edges are
undirected meaning you know if
one has a neighbor two well two is also
going to have a neighbor 1 in its
neighbor list
so let's say that 1 is our entry point
in the graph what are we going to do you
can see initially our hash map is empty
what we're going to try to do is map the
old nodes
to the new nodes or the copy nodes so we
start at one so what's the first thing
we should do well obviously we should
create a copy of this
node that's what i'm gonna do so create
a copy of one
now this copy of one is not complete yet
right because take a look at the
original one it has two neighbors
three and two so what can i do
we know we're gonna have two neighbors
for node one right
can i just take these two original nodes
and then put them over here
three and two no i can't do that because
for these nodes three and two we
actually have to create copies of
them as well so you can see that this is
gonna be recursive
so first thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
go to its first neighbor which let's
just say it happens to be two in this
case right
so i'm gonna now i'm gonna i'm gonna
start cloning starting at two so
we're at two we're gonna create a clone
of two oh and by the way before i forget
before we make a clone of two we know we
just created a clone for one so what are
we gonna do
we're gonna map the original node one
to its now clone node once we're mapping
the old node
to the new node and i'm going to show
you why we're doing that in a second
so now we're going to go to node 2 right
and we're going to create a clone of
node 2. so let's create that clone
node 2. we're also going to add it to
our hashmap right we're mapping the
old node 2 to its clone so the clone
in blue is the new node
so now we've cloned one and we've cloned
two
and for two now let's look at two's
neighbors well
look you can see that it has a neighbor
of one
right and it has a neighbor of four so
first we're gonna end up trying to do is
create a clone for
two because we know that we have to in
the list of neighbors for two we have to
add the clone
one which we haven't done yet so what
we're gonna end up doing is we're gonna
try to clone one but we're gonna see
in our hash map look we already ended up
cloning
one so basically what i'm saying is now
we can say okay we can add
this edge that two is connected to one
that two has a neighbor
that happens to be one and basically
the reason i'm doing that is because we
know this edge is going to be undirected
it goes both
ways so that's what i'm trying to do
here so now we know that 2 is connected
to 1
we also know we have to clone node 4.
so now we're going to visit position 4.
let's create a clone for 4
so let's add it to our hash map as well
we're mapping the original node
4 to its clone so now we're at the node
4. we want to clone
4's neighbors first you see that 4 has a
neighbor
2 which we already cloned so we're going
to take this original node 4 right we
know the original node
we know the original node 4 has a as an
original neighbor of 2
so then we're going to take that 2 look
it up in our hash map see okay we
already created a
clone of it and this is the clone and
then we're gonna end up taking four and
connecting it to
two and let's just say that you know
when we created the node four we ended
up connecting two
to four so let's just make this edge go
both
ways because we know that originally the
edges are undirected
so now that we've for four we wanted to
create a clone of two
we also want to create a clone of its
second neighbor three
so now let's create a clone of three so
we know that four is going to be able to
connect
to this neighbor of three so we're
creating a clone for it
and we're gonna take the original three
node and map it to its
new copy node of three so now we're
almost done
right you can see that all four of the
nodes have been copied
but for three we haven't added threes
and neighbors right
three isn't ended up connecting to any
other nodes yet but we know in the
original three has two neighbors
the first neighbor is four so we're
going to say okay we know that
this 4 needs to have a clone but the
good thing is we already created a clone
for that node
and this is the clone so now we have it
so we're gonna take
three and ah and connect it to
four so we're gonna make this edge
basically double directed
and three also has another neighbor of
one and so basically what we need to do
is make a clone of that one but we
look in our hash map first and we see we
already cloned one
this is the clone so we're gonna take
three and
connect it to one right but wait we have
one last problem right this
one should also be connected to the
three right you're right and that's what
we're doing recursively now
so we originally started at one then we
went to two
then we went to four then we went to
three now what we're going to end up
doing is
reversing that because we remember we're
doing this recursively so we're gonna
pop back up to four
we're gonna see four has already cloned
its neighbors three already cloned its
neighbors
we're gonna pop back to two two already
cloned its neighbors
we're gonna pop back to one one we ended
up cloning
the neighbor two right but we didn't end
up
going this way so from three now we're
gonna end up
we're gonna end up checking okay did we
already clone three let's look in our
hash map yep we already did
so this is the clone that we created so
all we really need to do is make one
connected to three so basically make
this edge double directed
so now you can see that we finally
created a complete clone
of the graph we did this in o of n
time where n is basically the number of
edges plus the number of vertices right
the number of nodes plus the number of
edges connecting them because we have to
basically make a clone of each of these
and with that being said now let's jump
into the code
so we remember that we only need a
single data structure
old to new which is a hash map mapping
the old nodes to the new nodes and i'm
going to implement this in depth first
search
and you can see that this function is
nested in the outer function which just
makes things easier meaning that this
data structure doesn't need to be passed
into every single function call
but we do need to pass in everything
every time the node that we're visiting
so in depth first search we're going to
pass in the node
first thing we're going to check is if
the node is
in our hashmap if it is in our hashmap
then that means we already made a clone
of it
if we already made a clone of it then
i'm just going to return that clone
we don't need to create another clone so
if it exists return the new node
so if this statement doesn't execute
that means a clone doesn't already exist
so let's create that clone i guess i'll
call it a copy so we're going to create
a
copy of this node so we're going to use
the node constructor and the value we're
going to give it is the value of this
original node and we're also going to
take that copy and then add it to our
old to new hash map so
old to new so the old node is just node
and the new node is the copy
so we're mapping the old node to the
copy
and then we want to make copies of every
single
neighbor of the original node so
node.neighbors
let's go through every single neighbor
and let's run depth first search on that
neighbor
for the and so basically if we run debt
for search on that neighbor what it's
going to do is it's going to return
the copy that we end up creating and
with that copy what am i going to do
i'm going to take this old node or this
new node the copy that we made
and i'm going to take its list of
neighbors
and i'm going to append to that list of
this uh the return statement from this
debt first search call
so let's copy and paste that in here so
that's all i really really need to do
depth first search
and add it to the neighbors of this copy
that we just
made and once we're done making all
the copies of the neighbors then we can
return the copy that we just made in the
current function call and it's actually
that simple because
even though this is called that first
search it might even be better to call
this function
clone because cloning is basically what
we're doing we're taking the original
node and creating a clone
of that node and we're cloning all of
its neighbors recursively that's what
this recursive
call is right and then to the neighbors
that we're creating we're
adding them or appending them to the
list of neighbors of this node
and so it's actually the last thing to
do is easier than you would think we're
going to
call debt for search passing in the
original node that we're given in the
original function call
and then we're just going to return the
result of that
because that's going to give us the
connected graph it doesn't really matter
which
node we return i think so any node that
we end up returning
is good after the entire clone has been
made
oh and one last thing we forgot to check
one edge case the original node that
we're given could be
null so if the node
is non-null then we're going to call
this function return the result
else if the node is null we'll just
return
null so with that being said this
function
should work and there you go it's pretty
efficient even though
this indication makes it seem like it's
not i think if i ran it one more time it
would probably be closer to like 50 or
60 percent
but i hope this was helpful if you
enjoyed
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon